this time on life links our reporters
meet survivors of a horrific act FGM for
female genital mutilation and FGM is
this times hashtag yelder travels to
Senegal to meet a young woman working to
save girls from a life of pain in
Britain young learns that FGM is not
just an African problem and in Germany
Anna explores her reconstructive surgery
can heal not only the physical damage
damage done to two million girls each
year use a hashtag to join the
conversation
I'm welcomed by posters that plead for
an end to female genital mutilation and
sexual violence I'm in Senegal where one
in four women have had FGM here in the
southeastern village of Duque nearly
every woman is affected this lovely
upbeat atmosphere is not quite what I
expected on a reporting trip about this
topic but today's dancing is part of an
official event to celebrate changing
attitudes towards FGM the goal is to
abandon this long-held tradition to
achieve this 25 year old gundo is
working with the village elders the
custom in the sonic ethnic group is that
most women were cut when they were
infants that's not unusual for Senegal
where 75% of girls who undergo FGM are
younger than 4 that was this is a film
our country let's assume sex Tekelec
season second second
Damini this is a true south make lousy
cement nasty they will feel is enough a
public TV until recently it was
unthinkable for a mother to take a stand
against this tradition some of this
change is due to strong women like
Gundam she works for an international
aid organization called toss tan that's
providing facts about FGM gündüz mother
lacked information and followed
tradition laughs it's good was it a OC
visit a live man concert concert a
particular and Valentini let me know I'm
telling him that and Molly not our
olymic ago I'm telling ya it's good
timing for secrecy get them to marry
that's what's up boxer can you keep up
with Scott as a particle a little follow
me let's go the complete epic Oprah a
clip of us PL o see in the South Africa
in this hypothesis Papa itself Cobra
Marcus apart whenever possible you know
Parker Colossus the Amanda party these
are prophecy this is the first time that
mother and daughter have talked about
the rich
before today it was - boom traditions
dictate the different ways women are cut
80% of women are cut in one of two ways
either the clitoris is cut off or the
clitoris and inner labia are cut away in
the most extreme type the outer genitals
are largely cut away and the woman is
sewn closed with only a small hole left
for urination and menstruation in all
140 million women across the globe are
affected by FGM
thirty thousand girls and women living
in Germany have had genital mutilation
in high-rise development on the
outskirts of Dortmund I meet with 22
year old Ben - she shares a small
apartment with her son a girlfriend has
come along with her daughter for support
Ben - tells me her story of being cut at
the age of 12 when she was growing up in
Gambia they told us that in one week
time you girls will be going for FTM but
you're going to kill your crocodile
imagine a teenage girl going to kill see
a color code I feel siekerka die and
kill that was so amazing and imagine if
they tell you that you going to a place
where the money will be flowing from the
tree you can have any amount of money
you need you will be eating apples
bananas and lots of amazing things so it
was only joy that came to our house and
we couldn't even wait for the day to
come the women of the family brought Ben
- and 30 other girls to a distant
village that was only open to women
there was a big celebration and her
grandmother danced for them but during
the dance Ben - noticed her grandmother
was crying yes he was singing in my
local language like if I can translate
the song in English is like the parts
that are flying inside the air you can
tell this my daughter that today her
shall I go with him we were attacked
Eagles that went what we came out list
less than thirty three girls were yet
according to our tradition they told us
that those skills were until by the
crocodile they was blindfolded and their
hands were tied
then they led them one by one to an
excise er a woman whose job it is to
perform FGM they've got my clitoris then
after fourteen that they you know
tormented tomaten party they used it on
Martin first to cover it these thematic
ways have to mix with the blood so that
is how they call the ceiling of the
virginity been to blood for days
afterward when she spoke out against the
tradition her community disowned her and
left her on the fringe
her father hoped to bring her back into
the community by forcing her to marry on
the wedding night the excise were
arrived for a second time they are
opening for you to slip with your money
this resort late like this they will cut
it into two only this age they will use
to force it inside you they have to
first this thing inside the vagina when
the blood come out the man have to jump
on top of you the man have to sleep with
you by force because if not it will if
it is as well together
Oh again
been to defended herself ran away on her
wedding night
and in response her father threatened to
kill her
her school helped her escape she made
the journey to Germany and was granted
asylum now she's making a new life here
and working as an apprentice to a cook
my body is lacking something very
important
yes something really important the most
important part of my body has been
removed and that is something that can
never be brought alive yeah it's like
killing somebody and the person can
never be brought alive yeah because a
dead person is always a dead father
venture says she's often thought of
suicide but she's the sole caregiver for
her son and she wants him to have a
better life than her own she's telling
her story because she feels this is her
only weapon in the fight against FGM
more girls and women are affected by FGM
in the UK than in any other country in
Europe an estimated 140,000 women and
girls who live here had to go through it
many of them are migrants from Africa I
meet nim Co she came to the UK from
Somalia as a little girl but during a
summer trip to their home country the
family decided to have her cut she was
seven years old
25 years later she's now an outspoken
activist who's changed the tone of the
debate on FGM in Britain it was very
much something that identified you and I
seem to think well I've had FGM I'm over
it and I'm getting on with my life and I
really wanted that conversation to carry
on but then I realize that if I do not
come forward and say hey I'm one of the
people that had it but I'm always I'm
also on the other side then people were
thinking well if you could have left Jim
then it could be anywhere and I'm like
exactly it's nothing to do with not
being educated what all these things is
to do with the lack of agency within
girls and within like a ghost be
protected but I know a lot of women in
this room of being like you know we do
so many things and I want to give him
the confidence there and also everybody
else there it's not you that's our fault
asbestos it's a society and that issue
that's our fault
and we can't and you can't get over it
it was like just normal really key to
the issue female genital mutilation was
made illegal in the UK in the 1980s but
in some parts of London the proportion
of women cut is estimated at up to 5%
the highest rate is in the borough of
Southwark in South London
during summer vacation young girls are
often sent back to the home country of
their parents and cut their
apparently 5% of women that's the
estimates around here like have been
affected by it yeah no I would never do
that ever ever ever bus so how do they
even get that pleasure off his legs I
wouldn't accept it in this country
because it's not part of the culture
here in the UK so I wouldn't really
accept it but if people I against it
because they're doing it in Africa
I think they should this is the culture
so we can't leave our country and go to
other people's country and tell them
what to do they've been doing it for
years
so it's sheer ignorance it's not it's
nothing to do with religion it's not
it's nothing I don't think is anything -
well if it is something to do with
culture its it's a crass culture that I
mean - I can't find the right district
if but it's its culture that needs to go
it's unlikely that this 2,000 year old
tradition will go away easily it's too
deeply embedded in society I visit an
old woman who's been an excise er for
decades she earned her living by
performing FGM and has cut countless
girls including her own granddaughters
she no longer works as an exciter and
says she stopped because she sees how
much it hurts women she describes to me
what she did to the girls until just
recently we develop for the air lamb
Seto Kaiba sunidhi feel it mortally the
time for a duel
Hera then we I'm a god
so you tell me much magenta
uhm doom not the young men and are
ruining it with him
sanitary the a medium era tan there are
mutually intimate rang in the Edam
portulaca come on you talk about giving
the Vavoom on you know what I'm know why
did him how hit mean Bundy on Jan gimme
hokey me what to me one day also her mo
willow and out me what attack around
there we know Yankee nickim mean they
worked even a meetin Yun hanmin Konami
Daniel Varley Jericho him Duke team and
telling me for hey Gazoo carbon moanin
for him but in a minute Hanuman unity
your damn hands it's giving them a lot
false it didn't include would world a
Pharisee a lot mediator nebari we a
person aku yang canonical igor gala and
one cool tell me lightly hand-holding
yummy I saw me doing it man waited
this is where doctors repair damage done
by excise errs today there are surgical
options to reconstruct parts of the
clitoris and to reform the labia
since 2013 roughly 70 patients were
treated in Berlin's fight Freeda
hospital it's one of only a few
hospitals worldwide that perform these
types of surgeries
the sentiment wilderness and FGM marmots
yuan had sisters married applauding
especially one which Dynamite's own
about cotton aspirin drama 16 each dish
cartinacow on TBS gotta go get em the
Arkansas back a few hot and manage media
alarm in Demon's an iron you are an
unfortunate each of us recon story with
Tiger comes freedom so universal
I learn about the devastating
psychological effects of FGM from this
young woman nine years ago she left her
home in Gambia and freed herself from a
forced marriage
fearing the hatred and hostility of her
family and the African community she
wants to remain anonymous this is the
first time she tells her story publicly
he said I were going to her party we're
gonna buy a nice dress for you I used to
love banana they told me they're gonna
buy banana for me so I just follow her
you get into a car then we go they left
me read the lady and her friends so I
did undress me I was naked they put me
down on a floor I lied they're like like
this face up I was lying on my back so
they hold my hand somebody have to sit
here someone pinned you yeah pin me down
and somebody was holding my legs one is
holding this one one is holding that one
they just caught I can't remember what
type of math do they use but they use
knife I was feeling the pain and I
didn't see anyone I know I know I was
young because I was seven nearly eight
so I need someone at least that I know
but no I just I'm just seen strangers
and they just left you there I just
loved it yeah they just left me there
and they take the order one I was the
first to do and they took the other one
so that one was reading reading reading
reading but they didn't care one day
when she was getting her first baby and
the first and the only one lesson left
in that group and the only one left and
so we'll start
when I'm having sex like you know people
like they cry because they like because
of pears or for me I cry because it's
beautiful for the past three years I
didn't have sex because European four I
can't so any man that I met he will just
stick with me for a once that's it you
will not want to see me again and
brought coming out of me still now I
know that when I will leave with it for
the rest of my life I never tell it to
anyone unless doctors the young woman
has applied for asylum in Britain she
doesn't want to go back to Gambia under
any circumstances she's afraid her
father will kill her men play a decisive
role when it comes to upholding the
abuse that is FGM Solomon is one of the
few male activists who fight against FGM
he's regularly trying to convince men to
spare their daughters why do you think
it's important for men to get involved
in the fight to stop this because I have
always argued that FGM is done on women
by Stanfill for men that is the
underlying cause the underlying reason
to control the sexuality of you know the
the woman and so that she stays loyal
and obedient to the man traditionally
FGM has been left to be seen as a woman
issue and I never get got involved you
know so the main have willingly which
thrown themselves and the woman have
happily continued that tradition they
don't get the men involved okay it is
seen as a human issue not as a messy
business women's business but when the
man decides to step in in a breaking
some kind of tradition says no it needs
to stop it here then I don't think they
can fight back and stop just not just
not was digital they seemed to change
it's true if you want to change
something you need to talk to the men in
Senegal men are the village heads and
make the important decisions
I ride with gundo to a neighboring
village the population here is part of a
different ethnic group they're Muslims
as well and all of the girls have to go
through genital mutilation gundo wants
to convince these villagers to finally
consider ending the tradition let's
please let them wanna I wanna see later
call you come up to level us this
quickly looks like a failed attempt the
atmosphere here is different much more
aggressive than in condos home village
without the consent of the men we can't
talk to the women
the village chief is not there even
though or perhaps because he knew we
were coming
it's clearly a rejection very much
because of Lucas over here in Sector
okay on feller I know and I'm part may
see a blue Sun pas de corps okay oh poor
you
it's good sit down point C to the C so
the power their product to Zuri want
reading book whose affair Leslie feels
cafes and there's a salon today I wanna
say you know will forever say it was
containers over whatever hopefully less
intrusive upon Cedar Fair sister assets
the men hide behind silence although she
often meets with rejection
kundo has had success in other villages
it only works at the village elders and
religious leaders are on board like the
Imam here in her home village of Dukie
Omaha for selenium oleg rezvov on land -
honey whatever our hunting howler 91
sarong Adam and Surya
hasari American drone y mató BD and wild
honey can focus on the important Briana
for money can cause of economy Orton no
con una empanada fauna came over and
linearly not ending and Aquila kV
once a month a group of up to 40 women
affected by FGM meet in Berlin here in
this self-help group invite freedom
hospital women have a space to tell
their stories it's a freedom they did
not have in Africa as time goes on the
group has only grown
we are the first camera team allowed to
film here
after the self-help group I meet Miriam
a few months ago she decided to have
reconstructive surgery at the age of
seven her story is as cruel as those of
the other women now she's on the mend
the answer yet and she didn't realize
now becomes that Sue is rubberman phone
arts and they had mirrors in Fortner
mine clitoris is now open given that
this dvn design for Mizzou a constant
sources are ishvara a smile moosh me
receive a league-high - Natalie shanks
of Valley shadow of Alzheimer disease
tough on gross problem then divider is
summation mice 5000 philipson and cam
she also has absolutely Cooper gonna be
Jewish and on my end she didn't that
hurt my concern was field field beza
also posh mares not envision a boyish
will receive all well if a mrs. Otis Mia
would have a speck anomalous TV Dada if
in total pain cook from your mood
afternoon of non water each was
miserable mission victus versus AG well
it's a field sphere as Oh Monceau in
[ __ ] II sang Wanda's had me initial
girl from a submission informal soccer
songs or Suzanne and for each phase of a
mission
enter deca seek to nourish her head for
a liner fresh Lawson want to miss zdenka
schmancer talk about often read
desertions have their information in
Africa
I would have liked to know more about
Miriam her history and her wishes for
the future but Miriam asked for some
rest after this first interview she
needs time to deal with the feelings
that arise from going through
reconstructive surgery and adapting to
her new life
there are only a handful of women in the
United Kingdom who openly address and
combat FGM women like Alomar to have
publicized the issue and put it on the
political agenda now Alomar too is
helping other women break the taboo as
well because most sufferers remain
silent they're afraid of how their
communities will react activists who
speak out I know of many who have to
move away from their homes because they
are seen as threats what does that
backlash look like specifically I would
give you from the snares like people
walking in the street and going like
this in your face or getting eggs thrown
at your face this is literal or you have
comments on social media or you get
letters in the polls so for any woman
they have to also be working and be
faced with this reality that they are in
that I'm gonna go back and face my
family I'm going to go back and face
those people that I said have done this
to me and they want to be loved they
want to be cared for they want to belong
somewhere because what you don't want is
to have women feeling even more so
ostracized often Alomar too is the first
stop for women who need assistance the
young woman who wishes to remain
anonymous has contacted her and with a
LeMat whose help she managed to finally
talk about the violence done to her
what's your dream for the future my
dream is like to work like charities
helping girls that goals like girls that
they forced to get marry or early
marriages or this FGM I just want people
to stop it so I'm gonna like be an
activist on that it was that important
to you yeah because I know what I go
through so I don't want people to be
victim like me or I don't know victim
survivors like me I want to help
survivors like me so that they can come
out and speak to themselves
it's a special challenge to break the
silence here gundo finds it difficult to
talk to me about the details although
she actively campaigns against FGM she
only wanted to talk about the
complications she had with her pregnancy
after her difficulties with childbirth
she assisted the maternity ward of the
village with women who was struggling
through the same issues is it a tree
Patti give Omar vpz heavily alcohol
3 para a poor the derivative of X so
France defenders have Aquila Cosmo this
Venn Twitter data Jessie entre way as we
say that Arafat get the past cassava
click CC ok a visa
once the paragraph here in Senegal many
girls is so not hard to removal of the
clitoris in Libya in the end
kundo revealed even more and told me
that the pain from cutting before birth
is far from the only problem the appear
to beaucoup de son general partner Appa
beaucoup de moi avec Toma ragazzi savato
/ - Taizo an apple an emesis avec la
funky Napa
it's easy TIPA TIPA TIPA TIPA tomato
only a victim Marie power the Sun I did
della Sera Tommy Mustafa man Pasadena
Paris who are answer mama de la Papa
refugee when a pirate draw the refugee
was he never tell Roger these twins came
into the world seven months ago they're
the children of the Midwife of the
maternity ward
yeah Gunda has three sons but she wants
a daughter you know that everything is
changing the street all to leafy
disregard WAP I you know do i you know
so far exceeds coolest abuse vinegar
it's a big dream but it has begun to be
realized as gundo works to help more
villages renounce this sad and tired
tradition in her home village the
daughter of the midwife is the first
generation to grow up unharmed